We all know what it feels like to get angry. Another driver cuts you off in traffic or runs a red light right in front of you. You miss out on a promotion to someone you feel is less deserving. Your kid stumps away yelling that they won't listen to you anymore. Your stomach churns, your pulse races, and you think, how dare they? Anger is a normal human emotion. A natural reaction when you feel that something or someone has done you wrong. But anger can also turn violent and dangerous.
我们都知道生气是什么感觉。在交通拥堵时，另一名司机突然插队，或者就在你面前闯红灯；你与一个你觉得配不上的人擦肩而过，错失了晋升的机会；你的孩子大喊大叫着走开，说再也不听你的话了。你的胃在翻腾，脉搏在加速，你心里想：他们怎么敢这样？愤怒是一种正常的人类情感。当你觉得某事或某人对你做了错事时，这是一种自然的反应。但愤怒也可能演变成暴力和危险。
It can ruin relationships and it can interfere with our health and our happiness. So how do you know when anger is healthy and when it's harmful? Are there effective strategies you can use to cope with anger when it's interfering with your life? What if your anger threshold is different from that of your partner? When you feel angry, is it better to let it all out or hold your emotions in? And how do you know if it's time to seek help from a psychologist or other mental health professional? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
它会毁掉人际关系，并干扰我们的健康和幸福。那么，你如何知道什么时候愤怒是健康的，什么时候是有害的？当愤怒干扰了你的生活时，有没有什么有效的策略可以用来应对它？如果你的愤怒阈值与伴侣的不同呢？当你感到愤怒时，是把情绪全部宣泄出来比较好，还是把情绪压抑在心里比较好？你又该如何知道是否是时候向心理学家或其他心理健康专家寻求帮助了？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
We have two guests today. First is Dr. Howard Kasinov, a professor emeritus of psychology at Hofstra University, where he was the founder and director of the Institute for the Study and Treatment of Anger and Aggression. Dr. Kasinov has more than 40 years of experience as a scientist and a clinical practice. studying anger and aggression management. Our second guest is Dr. Raymond Chip Tafraidy, a clinical psychologist and professor in the Department of Criminology and Criminal Justice at Central Connecticut State University. Dr. Tafrady frequently consults with criminal justice agencies and programs, community mental health centers, and private practices, and has trained thousands of professionals to work more effectively with adolescents and adults with difficult to change anger problems. Together, Dr. Kassanova and Dr. Tafredi have authored two books, Anger Management for Everyone,
我们今天有两位嘉宾。第一位是霍夫斯特拉大学（Hofstra University）心理学荣休教授霍华德·卡西诺夫博士（Dr. Howard Kassinove），他曾是该校愤怒与攻击研究与治疗研究所的创始人和主任。卡西诺夫博士在研究和临床实践愤怒与攻击管理方面拥有40多年的经验。我们的第二位嘉宾是雷蒙德·奇普·塔夫雷迪博士（Dr. Raymond Chip Tafrate），他是中康涅狄格州立大学（Central Connecticut State University）犯罪学和刑事司法系的临床心理学家兼教授。塔夫雷迪博士经常为刑事司法机构和项目、社区心理健康中心以及私人诊所提供咨询，并培训了数千名专业人员，以便更有效地与难以改变愤怒问题的青少年和成年人合作。卡西诺夫博士和塔夫雷迪博士共同撰写了两本书：《人人适用的愤怒管理》，
Ten Proven Strategies to Help You Control Anger and Live a Happier Life, and the Practitioner's Guide to Anger Management. Thank you both for joining me today. Our pleasure. Great to be her. Let's start with what we mean by anger. People often think that anger and aggression are synonymous, but they're not the same thing. So what is anger?
《帮助你控制愤怒并过上更幸福生活的十个行之有效的策略》以及《愤怒管理从业者指南》。非常感谢两位今天能参加我的节目。不客气，很高兴来到这里。让我们从我们所说的愤怒的含义开始。人们经常认为愤怒和攻击是同义词，但它们并不是一回事。那么什么是愤怒？
How is it different from aggression? And Dr. Kastanov, let's start with you on that one. You know, anger is a complex reaction to perceived threat. We can feel threatened when our children are hurt by other kids. We can feel threatened in the workplace. We can feel threatened by neighbors. There are all kinds of threats that exist in our lives. And anger emerges when we perceive that threat.
它与攻击有什么不同？卡西诺夫博士，让我们从你开始谈谈这个。你知道，愤怒是对感知到威胁的复杂反应。当我们的孩子被其他孩子欺负时，我们会感到受到威胁。我们在工作场所会感到受到威胁。我们可能会受到邻居的威胁。我们生活中存在各种各样的威胁。当我们感知到这种威胁时，愤怒就会产生。
And when I say it's complex, what I mean is, that when we become angry, we often have thoughts that go through our mind, like the boss is given the raise to another worker. He shouldn't have done that. This is a terrible, awful thing. So we have these thoughts that go through our mind. We also have a lot of behaviors. And by that, I mean, we will yell and scream and flail our hands around. We may engage in some kind of vengeance against the other person. And of course, there are physiological or biological reactions also to threat where our heart rate increases and our response to light increases and we secrete chemicals. And so it's this complex reaction, all of which has to be dealt with in therapy or in treatment.
当我说它很复杂时，我的意思是，当我们生气时，我们的脑海中经常会闪过这样的想法：老板给另一个员工加薪了。他不该这么做。这是一件可怕的、糟糕的事情。所以我们脑海中会有这些想法。我们也有很多行为。我的意思是，我们会大喊大叫、尖叫、挥舞双手。我们可能会对另一个人实施某种报复。当然，对威胁也会有生理或生物学上的反应，我们的心率会加快，我们对光的反应会增加，我们会分泌化学物质。所以这是一个复杂的反应，所有这些都必须在治疗中得到处理。
The second part, what's the difference between anger and aggression, is very interesting. Anger is primarily an internal response. We know we're angry. We feel it inside. We can be angry and other people may not know that we're angry. As a matter of fact, if you look in terms of international or national negotiations, if a person becomes angry, you're not supposed to let your opponent know about it. On the other hand, most people who become angry do not become aggressive.
第二部分，愤怒和攻击的区别是什么，非常有趣。愤怒主要是一种内部反应。我们知道我们生气了。我们在内心感受到了它。我们可以生气，而别人可能不知道我们生气了。事实上，如果你从国际或国内谈判的角度来看，如果一个人生气了，你是不应该让你的对手知道的。另一方面，大多数生气的人并不会变得具有攻击性。
We just become angry. It seethes inside of us. Maybe we talk to our marital partner about it, et cetera. Aggression, on the other hand, can definitely occur without any anger at all. Think for a moment about a hunter going out for the day to shoot. animals, that hunter is not angry at the animals. He or she sees it as an activity of the day. So anger can be followed by aggression, but most of the time it's not. Aggression can occur after anger, as I said, most of the time it's not, but aggression can be a totally
我们只是生气。它在我们内心翻腾。也许我们跟配偶谈论这件事，等等。另一方面，攻击完全可以在没有任何愤怒的情况下发生。试想一下，一个猎人出门去射杀动物，那个猎人并没有对动物生气。他或她认为这只是当天的活动。所以愤怒之后可能会有攻击，但大多数时候没有。攻击可以在愤怒之后发生，正如我所说，大多数时候没有，但攻击可以是一种完全
independent behavior where the goal is to harm, to engage in some. some kind of behavioral harm without any anger at all. Chip, did you want to say something? Yes, and I think this is a common misunderstanding about anger. People think of the word anger and the next word that pops into their mind is aggression. And in a lot of anger training workshops, we sometimes do this exercise. We ask all the participants and they're usually practitioners of different types. We ask them, how many of you have experienced anger in the past week?
独立的行为，其目标是伤害，从事某种行为上的伤害而没有任何愤怒。奇普，你想说点什么吗？是的，我认为这是对愤怒的一个普遍误解。人们一想到愤怒这个词，脑海中蹦出的下一个词就是攻击。在许多愤怒培训研讨会中，我们有时会做这样一个练习。我们询问所有的参与者，他们通常是不同类型的从业人员。我们问他们，你们中有多少人在过去一周内经历过愤怒？
And it's normal for people to feel angry, you know, one or two times a week. That's just typical. And so when you ask a roomful of people to let you know if they've experienced anger, pretty much all the hands in the room go up. And then you ask a second question. How many of you have assaulted somebody, destroyed property, punched a wall, kicked somebody in the past week when you were angry, and there's almost no hands that go up in the room.
人们感到愤怒是很正常的，你知道，一周一两次。这很典型。所以当你问满屋子的人让他们告诉你他们是否经历过愤怒时，屋里几乎所有的手都举起来了。然后你问第二个问题。你们中有多少人在过去一周生气时殴打过某人、破坏过财产、砸过墙、踢过某人？屋里几乎没有人举手。
But the most interesting question is the next one. How many of you at some point in your life, when you were angry, have hit, struck, pushed, kick somebody? And it's an uncomfortable moment, but almost all the hands in the room go up again. And so I think what Howie and I are saying is that aggression is the least common response often when people are angry. And on studies where they actually count and measure this, anger is the thing that happens kind of, it's like the least common thing on most of these surveys.
但最有趣的问题是下一个。你们中有多少人在你生命中的某个时刻，当你生气时，曾经殴打、打击、推搡、踢过某人？这是一个令人尴尬的时刻，但屋里几乎所有的手又都举起来了。所以我想我和霍威要表达的是，当人们生气时，攻击往往是最不常见的反应。在那些真正对此进行清点和测量的研究中，愤怒发生的情况，在大多数这些调查中，它就像是最不常见的事情。
However, as the hands in the room exercise shows that all of us know the connection between anger and aggression. Most of us have been there and we understand the destructive connection that can occur. And I would say for most of the listeners on this podcast, probably some of your most cringe-worthy moments occurred when you were angry at somebody. So to follow up on that, is there a, quote, normal level of anger, a normal amount of anger that people could expect to experience during a week, during a month, during a lifetime? Yeah, you know, Chip gives the notion of once or twice a week is kind of normal. We use four criteria.
然而，正如满屋子的手举起来的练习所表明的那样，我们所有人都知道愤怒和攻击之间的联系。我们大多数人都经历过，我们理解可能发生的破坏性联系。我想对于这个播客的大多数听众来说，你最尴尬的时刻可能都发生在你在某人生气的时候。为了接着这个话题，是否存在一个所谓的“正常水平的愤怒”，即人们在一个星期、一个月或一生中可以预期经历的正常愤怒量？是的，你知道，奇普提出了每周一到两次的看法，这算是正常的。我们使用四个标准。
We ask, is the anger that you're experiencing too frequent, too intense, does it endure for too long? And is your anger helpful? Is it working in your family, in your job? Is it making you a more productive citizen? So if you're becoming angry once a week, twice a week, if it's of low level, if it doesn't endure, and by that I mean you don't let the anger fester for days and weeks and months, and if your anger is serving as a signal, I would say.
我们问：你经历的愤怒是不是太频繁了？是不是太强烈了？是不是持续时间太长了？你的愤怒有用吗？它在你的家庭、工作中有用吗？它有没有让你成为一个更有成效的公民？所以，如果你每周生气一次、两次，如果它的程度很低，如果它没有持续很久——我的意思是，你没有让愤怒溃烂数天、数周和数月——如果你的愤怒正在充当一种信号，我会说，
In other words, let's take that workplace example again. the boss hires somebody and that other person is getting some extra benefits. And you're aware of this. And you kind of become a little bit agitated, a little bit. Then the anger is serving as a useful signal to talk to the boss and say, you know, I've been here for a long time. And this new guy or new woman has a better desk or has better working hours or things like that. And I'd like to talk to you about that. So, yes, not too intense, not too enduring, not too frequent, and helpful. That's the sign of good anger. So then, is there a clinical anger disorder? And if so, what are the hallmarks? Well, you know, Chip and I, and Chip, we can both answer this. Regrettably, there is not
换句话说，让我们再次以工作场所为例。老板雇用了某人，而那个人得到了一些额外的福利。你注意到了这一点。你有点激动，有点生气。然后愤怒就成了一个有用的信号，去跟老板谈谈，说：“你知道，我在这里工作很长时间了。这个新来的男同事或女同事有更好的办公桌、更好的工作时间或类似的东西。我想和你谈谈这件事。”所以，是的，不过分强烈，不过分持久，不过分频繁，而且有用。这就是良好愤怒的标志。那么，是否存在临床愤怒障碍？如果是这样，它的特征是什么？嗯，你知道，奇普和我，奇普，我们都可以回答这个问题。遗憾的是，目前并没有
an official diagnosis that's a clinical anger disorder. And I would say, you know, think about this. Human beings were brought up as part of the fight or flight reaction. So anger is an approach emotion and it occurs when you feel threatened. Anxiety is a withdrawal emotion. And if you feel threaten you withdraw. We have lots of anxiety diagnoses, but we've had no anger diagnoses. And when we try to bring this up to our colleagues, we don't make much headway at all. Why do you think they're resistant to that? I think because anger is considered to be a moral emotion. And by that I mean, oh, you're suffering from anxiety. Oh, you poor person. I feel so sad for you. I feel so bad for you. And we better have all these diagnoses and
一个官方诊断被称为临床愤怒障碍。我想说，你知道，想想这个：人类是作为战斗或逃跑反应的一部分被抚养长大的。所以愤怒是一种趋近情绪，当你感到受到威胁时它就会发生。焦虑是一种回避情绪，如果你感到受到威胁，你就会退缩。我们有很多焦虑诊断，但我们没有愤怒诊断。当我们试图向同事提起这件事时，我们根本没有取得什么进展。你认为他们为什么对此有抵抗力？我认为因为愤怒被认为是一种道德情感。我的意思是：哦，你正在遭受焦虑。哦，你这个可怜的人。我为你感到很难过。我为你感到很糟糕。我们最好有所有这些诊断和
treatments to help you. Anger, on the other hand, is you shouldn't have done it. You're an evil person. I want to punish you. And that doesn't lead to diagnoses. That leads to criminal justice intervention. Chip, did you want to? Yeah, I think there's a lot of reasons why anger has been ignored historically. And you have to kind of almost go back to the Western philosophers who got it right, who really labeled anger as a sort of significant human problem. And then along came psychology, and anger and aggression became sort of intertwined in psychoanalytic theory, the idea that everyone has sort of an innate aggressive drive. And the behaviorists also kind of lumped anger and aggression together. The idea that anger is just sort of a weaker expression of aggression,
治疗来帮助你。另一方面，愤怒则是：你不应该这么做。你是一个邪恶的人。我想惩罚你。这不会导致诊断。这会导致刑事司法干预。奇普，你想……是的，我认为历史上愤怒被忽视有很多原因。你几乎不得不追溯到那些做对了事的西方哲学家，他们真正把愤怒贴上了某种重大人类问题的标签。然后心理学出现了，愤怒和攻击在精神分析理论中纠缠在一起，这种观点认为每个人都有一种与生俱来的攻击驱动力。行为主义者也把愤怒和攻击混为一谈。这种观点认为愤怒只是攻击的一种较弱的表达方式，
And then we get to another area where they've got it right, emotion researchers. Emotion researchers have suggested that there's a handful of basic emotions that all human beings are capable of experiencing. They're interwoven into the fabric of our sort of evolution. And anger is one of those basic emotions. It's on everybody's list. And so I think that that's one of the reasons why anger's been ignored is just the sort of historical place that anchor has had in psychology.
然后我们来到了另一个他们做对了的领域：情感研究人员。情感研究人员提出，所有人类都有能力体验少数几种基本情绪。它们交织在我们进化的结构中。愤怒就是其中一种基本情绪。它在每个人的清单上。所以我认为，愤怒被忽视的原因之一就是愤怒在心理学中一直处于某种历史地位。
and sometimes we refer to anger as the forgotten emotion because there's no diagnostic category where the emotional excess is primarily anger. And in fact, anger is rarely mentioned in DSM. It's always a secondary symptom to other problems. And there's another, I think, more practical reason that as psychologists, when we pick our areas of study, we spent our life studying anxiety and depression. And maybe it's because anxious and depressive individuals are. are a little easier to work with.
有时我们把愤怒称为“被遗忘的情绪”，因为没有哪个诊断类别的 эмоциональный 过度主要表现为愤怒。事实上，愤怒在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中很少被提及。它总是其他问题的次要症状。我想还有另一个更实际的原因：作为心理学家，当我们选择研究领域时，我们毕生都在研究焦虑和抑郁。也许是因为焦虑和抑郁的个体比较容易共事。
Angry clients can be difficult. They can be unpredictable, unpleasant. And I think in some ways, professionals have not embraced people with anger problems. So let me ask if there is a significant gender difference in how people tend to experience and express anger. Do women or men get angry more often, or do they just express anger differently? I'm actually kind of interested as to whether or not Chip and I will have the same answer. I'll start if I can't shift and then we'll see what you say.
愤怒的客户可能很难相处。他们可能是不可预测的、令人不快的。我认为在某些方面，专业人士并没有真正接纳有愤怒问题的人。那么请问，在人们倾向于体验和表达愤怒的方式上，是否存在显著的性别差异？女性或男性生气的频率更高，还是他们只是表达愤怒的方式不同？我其实有点好奇我和奇普的答案是否会一样。如果我不能换一种方式，我先开始，然后我们看看你怎么说。
My answer is no. My answer is that the triggers that set us off the perceived unfairness and the reactions are pretty much the same. Some early studies show that women would cry more when they were angry and men would not cry more. Some studies that I've read would say that. women are more likely to talk it out rather than men. But, you know, when I look at the database, I think men and women are pretty much equal in anger. Now, not in aggression, of course,
我的回答是“没有”。我的回答是，引发我们生气的导火索——被感知的对立和不公以及反应——几乎是一样的。一些早期研究表明，女性在生气时会哭得更多，而男性哭得不会那么多。我读过的一些研究会说，女性更有可能通过倾诉来解决问题，而不是男性。但是，当我查看数据库时，我认为男性和女性在愤怒方面几乎是平等的。当然，在攻击方面不是，
because men have larger muscles, larger body mass, and can be more aggressive and do my damage. But with regard to anger, I think the answer is pretty much, it's an equal opportunity emotion. What's your answer, Chip? I'm not sure. I've come to the same conclusion. And I want to go back to one of the first treatment studies that Howie and I did. And this was in the 1990s. And we were quite naive then. And we really thought anger was a male problem. And so we kind of put up advertisements for men who were between the ages of 25 and 50. And the ads went something like this. Are you a man between 25 and 50 and you struggle controlling your anger? And if so, please give our clinic a call.
因为男性的肌肉更发达、体重大得多，可能更具攻击性并造成更多伤害。但就愤怒而言，我认为答案基本上是：它是一种机会均等的情绪。你的答案是什么，奇普？我不确定。我得出了相同的结论。我想回到我和霍威做的第一项治疗研究。那是在20世纪90年代。我们当时相当天真。我们真的认为愤怒是男性的问题。所以我们为25到50岁之间的男性张贴了广告。广告大概是这样的：你是一个25到50岁、难以控制自己愤怒的男性吗？如果是这样，请给我们的诊所打电话。
We'd like to talk with you and offer you a free treatment for your anger. And so we would get calls. And back then we had an answering machine, right? So we'd go to the clinic and play the calls from the answering machine. And I'll never forget that we got a couple calls that sounded like this. You know, I saw your ad and I have an anger problem and I'd like free treatment, but I'm a woman. and you people are sexist. And after getting a handful of calls like that, we started to wonder, maybe these women are right,
我们想和你谈谈，并为你提供免费的愤怒治疗。所以我们会接到电话。当时我们有一个答录机，对吧？所以我们会去诊所播放答录机里的电话。我永远不会忘记我们接到过几个听起来像这样的电话：你知道，我看到了你的广告，我有愤怒问题，我想得到免费治疗，但我是一个女人，你们这些人是性别歧视者。在接到几个这样的电话后，我们开始怀疑，也许这些女性是对的，
you know? And so I very much agree with the idea that in all sorts of different clinical settings, you'll see anger as a problem for both men and women. And it's definitely a mistake to assume that women don't suffer from anger problems. Well, let's talk for a minute about adaptive and maladaptive anger. The question is, is anger always bad for you? Well, the answer to that is no. There is both adaptive and maladaptive anger. I'd go back to the point of anger when it's adaptive is a signal. It's not of extreme intensity or duration, but it's a signal that something is going wrong. When you feel angry inside, you want to say, what's going on in my life? What's going on with my child? Is it important to express the anger? at this point. Take the example for a moment of your parent with a young child. Let's say the child
你知道吗？所以我非常赞同这样一种观点：在各种不同的临床环境中，你会发现愤怒对男性和女性来说都是一个问题。假设女性不会遭受愤怒问题的困扰绝对是一个错误。好吧，让我们花一分钟时间讨论适应性愤怒和适应不良愤怒。问题是，愤怒对你来说总是坏事吗？嗯，这个答案是否定的。既有适应性愤怒，也有适应不良愤怒。我会回到这个观点：当愤怒具有适应性时，它是一个信号。它的强度或持续时间不是极端的，但它是一个信号，表明有什么事情正在出问题。当你内心感到愤怒时，你会想：我的生活里发生了什么？我的孩子身上发生了什么？在这一点上表达愤怒重要吗？以有幼童的父母为例。比方说，孩子
is three or four years old. Chaka walk, and it's an inner city child, and the child runs into the street and barely misses being hit by a bus. Is that at time to say, oh, honey, please don't do that, or is that at time to kind of be a little aroused and agitated and say to the child, never do that again? In that kind of situation, you want what we call one trial learning. You can't expect to take 10 or 15 trials of the child running into the street before you try to control his or her behavior, right? So in that sense, the anger for the parent is a signal to take a.
大约三四岁。如果一个内城区的孩子在走路时突然冲向马路，差点被公共汽车撞到，这时候我们是该说“噢，宝贝，请别那样做”，还是该表现得有点激动、情绪高涨地对孩子说“再也别那样了”？在这种情况下，你需要我们所说的“一次性学习”。你不能指望孩子冲向马路十次或十五次后，你才去尝试控制他或她的行为，对吧？所以在这种意义上，父母的愤怒是一个采取行动的信号。
an effective action. Let's talk for a minute about people who are in relationships where the level of anger and anger tolerance is really different. So say one partner grew up in a household with a great deal of anger expression while the other came from a background where anger wasn't acceptable, just wasn't expressed or rarely expressed. Can such a couple reach some kind of a detente that works for both of them and if so, how? Well, it's kind of interesting because I think in all of the way.
采取有效的行动。我们花一分钟来聊聊那些在人际关系中愤怒水平和愤怒耐受度截然不同的伴侣。比如，一方在一个极少压抑愤怒、经常表达愤怒的家庭中长大，而另一方则来自一个愤怒不可接受、根本不表达或极少表达的背景。这样的一对伴侣能达成某种对双方都奏效的缓和状态吗？如果能，又是如何做到的？嗯，这挺有意思的，因为我认为在所有的方式中。
all relationships, there has to be some kind of detent about lots of things, not only anger, but about how you spend your money and what kind of religion do you want to bring a child up in, or how often do you want to go on vacation? And no man and woman, let's say, or no two partners who get together are going to be the same on any of these levels, including anger. So for me, and again, I'm interested in Chip's reaction, for me, the most important part of making your relationship work is what we call assertiveness training. And by that I mean, not the common definition, but assertiveness really means the proper and appropriate expression of emotion and desire for change. So those couples that you mentioned, both partners, have to say things like, take an example,
在所有的关系中，对许多事情都必须有某种程度的缓和，不仅是愤怒，还包括钱怎么花、你想把孩子培养成什么信仰的人，或者你想多久去一次度假。假设没有哪个男人和女人，或者说没有哪两个在一起的伴侣在这些层面上是完全相同的，包括愤怒在内。所以对我来说，再次声明，我很想知道奇普的反应，对我来说，让你的关系正常运转的最重要部分是我们所说的“自信训练”。我指的不是那个通常的定义，自信实际上意味着正确、恰当地表达情感以及对改变的渴望。所以你提到的那些伴侣，双方都必须说这样的话，举个例子，
when you spend so much of your money on clothing, and I observe that, I feel kind of annoyed, not angry, bitter, hostile, rageful, but I feel annoyed. And I'd like to talk to you about that, because my sense is I'd like to spend more of our money on vacations, and you'd seem to want to spend more of it on clothing, let's talk about this and get it onto the table. So open discussion starting off with the feeling. I feel annoyed. I feel mildly angry.
当你把那么多的钱花在买衣服上时，我注意到这一点，我感到有点恼火——不是愤怒、痛苦、敌意、狂怒，而是我感到恼火。我想和你谈谈这件事，因为我的感觉是，我想把更多的钱花在度假上，而你似乎想把更多的钱花在买衣服上，我们来谈谈这件事，把它摆到台面上来。所以开诚布公的讨论要从感受开始。我感到恼火。我感到有点生气。
I feel somewhat agitated. Let's talk about it. That's the way to get through this. Right, but not accusatory. Not accusatory, right. As a matter of fact, I'm happy you say that, Kim, because accusatory verbalizations are unfortunately a major part of anger. Think of it in terms of child rearing, you know.
我感到有点激动。我们来谈谈吧。这才是解决问题的方法。对，但不是指责性的。不是指责性的，对吧。事实上，金，我很高兴你这么说，因为不幸的是，指责性的言辞是愤怒的一个主要部分。想想抚养孩子的过程，你知道的。
You make me so angry, saying to your daughter or son. You cause so much problems, so many problems for me. So, yeah, you don't want any of that blame. You know, it's an interesting question, Kim. I'm kind of smirking here on the side because I don't recall ever seeing a study looked at different kinds of couples and their anger patterns and looking at potential compatibility. And so there's a lot of unanswered questions in the anger arena. I would just say that we tend to grow through relationships and having close relationships with others helps us question our own
你让我太生气了，对女儿或儿子这样说。你给我制造了这么多的麻烦，这么多的麻烦。所以，是的，你不需要任何这种指责。你知道，这是一个有趣的问题，金。我在这里有点暗自窃笑，因为我不记得曾见过有研究探讨过不同类型的伴侣及其愤怒模式，以及研究潜在的相容性。所以在愤怒这个领域还有很多未解的问题。我只想说，我们往往通过人际关系成长，与他人建立亲密关系有助于我们审视自己的
patterns. But the example you brought up raises all sorts of questions. So at the extreme ends, you have people that are kind of avoidance and anything that's uncomfortable, they won't discuss or talk about. And on the other extreme, you have people that engage in intimidating and threatening behaviors that shut others down. And so I'd have to imagine that if you have a couple where partners are on the extreme ends of both of those, on different ends of the extremes on both of those dimensions, that it's probably not going to go very well. Well, let's talk about the idea of catharsis, so that some people feel that when you're angry or even just stressed that the best thing to do is scream and yell and let it out. In the past few years, we've seen rage
模式。但你提出的这个例子引发了各种各样的问题。所以在极端情况下，有些人会选择回避，任何让人感到不舒服的事情他们都不愿讨论或谈论。而在另一个极端，有些人会采取恐吓和威胁的行为，把其他人压制得哑口无言。所以我想象不出，如果一对伴侣处在所有这些维度的极端两端、处在不同极端的对立面，那这段关系大概不会有什么好结果。好吧，我们来谈谈宣泄的概念，有些人认为，当你生气甚至只是感到压力时，最好的做法就是大喊大叫、发泄出来。在过去的几年里，我们看到了发泄屋
rooms, for example, where people pay money to go into a room and scream and smash things. Dr. DeFredi, let me ask you, what do you think of this idea? Do rage rooms and primal screams help people deal effectively with anger and frustration? Or is this counterproductive? In terms of people who struggle with anger difficulties, it's counterproductive. And And this kind of worries me because the treatment landscape right now seems a little bit like the Wild West. And what I mean by that is you have all sorts of different practitioners. You have folks that are licensed and credentialed. You have what I would describe as life coaches who offer their opinions.
例如，人们花钱进入一个房间尖叫并砸碎东西。德弗雷迪博士，请问您怎么看这个想法？发泄屋和原始呐喊能帮助人们有效地应对愤怒和挫败感吗？还是说这适得其反？对于那些挣扎于愤怒困扰的人来说，这是适得其反的。而且这让我有点担忧，因为现在的治疗领域看起来有点像狂野西部。我的意思是，你会有各种各样不同的从业人员。有获得执照和资质的人。还有我所说的提供意见的生活教练。
And then you have other people that are kind of advice givers and let's call them influencers. And there's lots of mythology and misinformation out there. And catharsis is one of those. And I saw this on my local news channel the other day. They were talking about primal scream. And I was really kind of shocked. But this is a problematic intervention. And so you can think of anyone who suffers from emotional excess.
然后还有其他人，他们有点像给建议的人，我们称他们为网红。外面有很多神话和错误信息。宣泄就是其中之一。前几天我在当地的新闻频道上看到了这个。他们在谈论原始呐喊。我真的感到有点震惊。但这是一种有问题的干预手段。所以你可以把任何遭受情感过剩困扰的人想成是这样。
So let's say depression or anxiety. You would never turn to someone who's suffering from depression and say, hey, you know, if you don't have the energy to go to work today and you're not feeling confident, just go back to bed. right? You wouldn't take someone who's anxious and say, you know, when you're at the cocktail party and you feel a little bit activated, just walk out of the room and leave the party and avoid it. And so that's kind of what catharsis is. We're telling people, when you're angry, go with the action tendency that's built into the emotion. And really, the trick is to sort of do the opposite of that, is to fight against the action tendency and to kind of ask yourself the question, you know,
比方说抑郁或焦虑。你绝不会对一个抑郁的人说：“嘿，你知道的，如果你今天没有精力去上班，又感觉没有自信，那就回床上躺着吧。”对吧？你不会对一个焦虑的人说：“你知道的，当你在鸡尾酒会上感到有点情绪激活时，直接走出房间离开派对，避开它就行了。”这其实就是宣泄的做法。我们在告诉人们，当你生气时，要顺应情绪中内置的行动倾向。而实际上，诀窍恰恰相反，是要做与此相反的事，去对抗这种行动倾向，并问自己这样一个问题：
where's my anger taking me in this moment? and can you try some different behaviors? And so when people are anxious, we ask them not to avoid. When people are depressed, we ask them to push themselves against that feeling of, you know, pulling back from their lives. And when people are angry, we ask them to not give in to the urge to yell and scream and vent and punch and hit things. And so there's been a number of studies on this.
“此时此刻我的愤怒把我带向了何方？”你能尝试一些不同的行为吗？因此，当人们感到焦虑时，我们要求他们不要回避。当人们感到抑郁时，我们要求他们克服那种从生活中退缩的感觉。而当人们愤怒时，我们要求他们不要屈服于大喊大叫、宣泄、猛砸和击打物体的冲动。所以这方面已经有很多研究了。
There's been studies in the 70s, 80s, 90s, and a couple in the 2000s. Almost no one in the academic arena is studying this anymore because we know the answer. This is actually an intervention that makes people worse because what you're practicing is connecting the internal emotion of anger with problematic verbal behaviors or aggressive behaviors. It's interesting because the section of APA's website that offers information for controlling anger before it controls you is consistently one of the most accessed areas of the entire site. And what that says to me is that people are having anger problems and they don't know where to go. to get the help? Do you think as a society that we're giving people the information and the tools that they need to understand and control their anger? Well, of course, I can put in a plug for the American Psychological Association because podcasts like this and some of the other informational
在70年代、80年代、90年代以及2000年代都有过相关研究。学术界几乎没有人再研究这个了，因为我们已经知道了答案。这实际上是一种会让情况变得更糟糕的干预措施，因为你所练习的是将内在的愤怒情绪与有问题的言语行为或攻击性行为联系起来。有趣的是，美国心理协会（APA）网站上提供关于“在愤怒控制你之前控制愤怒”信息的板块，一直是整个网站访问量最大的区域之一。这向我说明，人们正在经历愤怒问题，却不知道该去哪里寻求帮助。你认为作为一个社会，我们是否在向人们提供理解和控制愤怒所需的信息和工具呢？嗯，当然，我可以为美国心理协会打个广告，因为像这样的播客以及你所拥有的一些其他信息
resources that you have really does help the public. We do try to get scientific information out to the public. And this notion of catharsis is like one of the most important areas because it's shocking to me that after all of these years, the question still comes up. And as Chip said, we know the answer. If you practice being angry, you will become more effective at being angry. There's no such thing as letting it out. And by the way, I would just use that term. It's not like you have two quarts of anger inside of you and you're going to let it out. Like the historic notion of bloodletting will let it out, you know. What it is is behavioral practice.
资源确实对公众有帮助。我们确实在努力将科学信息传递给公众。而这个宣泄的概念是最重要的领域之一，因为令我震惊的是，经过这么多年，这个问题仍然会被提出来。正如奇普所说，我们知道答案。如果你练习愤怒，你就会变得更擅长愤怒。根本没有“把情绪放出来”这回事。顺便说一句，我只想用这个词。这并不像你体内有两夸脱的愤怒，然后你要把它放出来。就像历史上放血疗法的概念一样，把它放出来，你知道的。实际上这是行为练习。
And if you practice yelling and screaming and throwing and hitting and breaking, you're going to become more effective at yelling and screaming and hitting and breaking, etc. So if I have an anger management issue and I go to see a psychologist or another licensed practitioner who's going to help me, what can I expect? What will that person tell me I should be doing to get control of my life and my anger? It really depends on the practitioner and how they were trained. And so we have to have a little truth in advertising here that we don't know as much about anger as we do anxiety and depression.
如果你练习大喊大叫、尖叫、扔东西、殴打和破坏，你就会变得更擅长大喊大叫、尖叫、殴打和破坏，等等。所以，如果我有愤怒管理问题，我去看心理学家或其他能帮助我的持证从业人员，我能期待什么？这个人会告诉我应该做些什么来掌控自己的生活和愤怒？这 realmente 取决于从业人员以及他们的受训背景。所以在这里我们必须有一点诚实的广告，那就是我们对愤怒的了解不如对焦虑和抑郁的了解那么多。
And so there's a lot of variability, I think, in. how treatment is delivered. I think both of us can speak to what some of the best practices might look like. And one of the first steps is to understand what anger looks like in the context of the person's life. And so not everyone's anger patterns are the same. People cause damage to different parts of their lives, their relationships, their work lives. Some people have trouble with impulsiveness and aggression. And so it's not a cookie cutter approach. And so we like to start off by analyzing our client's individual episodes of anger and understand the components that make up those anger episodes. And once we understand that, it becomes a little bit more obvious to the client
因此我认为治疗的实施存在很大的变异性。我们两个都可以谈谈最佳实践可能是什么样子的。第一步是要了解愤怒在一个人的生活背景下是什么样子的。因此，并不是每个人的愤怒模式都是相同的。人们会对他们生活的不同部分造成破坏，包括人际关系、工作生活。有些人有冲动和攻击性问题。所以这不是一种千篇一律的方法。因此，我们喜欢从分析客户个体的愤怒发作事件开始，并了解构成这些愤怒事件的各个组成部分。一旦我们理解了这一点，对于客户来说就会变得更明显
and to us what areas we might look at in terms of intervention. You know, it's interesting, you asked that question, Kim. And I want to come back to you for a moment. Look at the questions that you're asking. They are mostly what I'm going to call social interpersonal. And when Chip says we don't know as much about anger, and we have to therefore be careful and do a good interview and tailor our treatment, consider this. One of the outcomes of anger that we haven't spoken about is bad decision making. When you're angry, that may not be the time to ask your boss for a raise. We haven't spoken about that. We haven't spoken about the fact that there are lots of biophysical medical outcomes of sustained anger. Sustained anger over the years
对我们来说，在干预方面我们可以关注哪些领域也变得更明显。你知道，这很有趣，金，你问了那个问题。我想把话题再拉回你身上片刻。看看你问的问题。它们大多是我所谓的社会人际层面的问题。当奇普说我们对愤怒的了解没那么多，因此我们必须小心谨慎、做好访谈并量身定制治疗方案时，请考虑这一点。我们尚未谈论的愤怒后果之一就是糟糕的决策。当你生气时，那可能不是向你的老板要求加薪的时候。我们没有谈过这一点。我们没有谈过这样一个事实，即持续的愤怒会带来许多生物物理医学方面的后果。多年来持续的愤怒
is associated with high blood pressure, digestive problems, heart disease, stroke. right? So as clinicians, we also want to look into those factors, into the cognitive factors. We haven't spoken too much, and I must say Chip is an expert in this area in terms of the effects of anger on arrest and incarceration and the criminal justice system. I mean, it's such a broad negative emotion when it becomes extreme that we really have a lot more to learn. And I think also in terms of what we're seeing in society at large, it seems like there's almost a kind of virality. Is that the right word, where my being angry can trigger other people to be angry. I'm thinking, for example, of the Ahmed Arbery case that was just tried in Georgia, where, you know, these neighbors all got together and fed off of each other. I mean, is that a typical thing where people who are angry feed other angry people? You know, there's a wonderful word that I learned a few years ago called emmification. E. M. Emnification. It means finding an enemy. And yeah, you may live in a community where one person is targeted as an enemy.
与高血压、消化问题、心脏病、中风有关。对吧？所以作为临床医生，我们也希望研究这些因素、认知因素。我们没有谈太多，我必须说奇普是这方面的专家，即愤怒对逮捕、监禁和刑事司法系统的影响。我的意思是，当愤怒达到极端时，它是一种如此广泛的负面情绪，以至于我们真的还有很多东西需要学习。而且我也认为，就我们在整个社会中看到的情况来看，这似乎几乎有一种病毒式的传播。这是正确的词吗？即我的愤怒可以触发其他人也感到愤怒。例如，我想到刚刚在佐治亚州受审的阿默德·阿尔贝里（Ahmaud Arbery）案，你知道，这些邻居聚在一起，互相情绪传染。我的意思是，这是一种典型的情况吗，即愤怒的人会滋养其他愤怒的人？你知道，几年前我学过一个绝妙的词叫“寻找敌人”（emmification）。“E-M-E-M-N-I-F-I-C-A-T-I-O-N”。它的意思是寻找一个敌人。是的，你可能生活在一个社区里，其中一个人被当作敌人来针对。
And then you wind up gossiping about that person and generating the anger against that person by talking about it constantly, by not giving that person. whether it's a minority man running down the street or whatever it is, not giving that person the benefit of the doubt, but saying we've known all along about that person. You know about that person, Kim. You know about that person, Chip. I know about that person. And yes, we do feed on each other and make it worse.
然后你最终会八卦那个人，通过不断谈论来激起对那个人的愤怒，不给那个人——无论是跑过街头的少数族裔男子还是其他什么人——不给那个人留有受益疑点的机会，而是说我们一直都了解那个人。金，你了解那个人。奇普，你了解那个人。我了解那个人。是的，我们的确会互相影响，让情况变得更糟。
And there's also this proliferation of reality television shows in American culture. And it seems like people that are selected to be on reality shows, often have poor emotion regulation, which can be entertaining to watch, right? But unfortunately, the types of nasty and verbal rants and sometimes the physically aggressive behaviors that you see on these shows get modeled as legitimate ways to resolve disagreements in the face of life's challenges. So I think that in some cases we've seen individuals who express their anger in destructive ways receive positive attention, maybe celebrity or some type of financial gain.
在美国文化中，真人秀节目的激增也是如此。似乎被选中参加真人秀节目的人往往情绪调节能力较差，这看点十足，对吧？但不幸的是，你在这些节目中看到的那些恶毒的言语咆哮有时甚至是身体攻击行为，被塑造成了面对生活挑战时解决分歧的合法方式。所以我认为，在某些情况下，我们看到那些以破坏性方式表达愤怒的个人获得了积极的关注，也许是名气或某种经济利益。
And unfortunately, these types of reactions in the real world tend to damage relationships and lead to suffering and losses for most people. Do you see cultural differences in anger? I mean, it always feels to me like we're particularly expressive society in that respect. And it feels to me like there are other cultures where it's actually verboten. I'm just wondering if you see that in your research. Well, you know, cultures are so broad. so many different types of cultures. If you go to Nepal, if you go to India, where Chip and I have both
而不幸的是，现实生活中的这类反应往往会破坏人际关系，并给大多数人带来痛苦和损失。你在愤怒中看到文化差异了吗？我的意思是，我总觉得在这方面我们是一个特别善于表达的社会。而且我觉得在其他文化中，这是绝对被禁止的。我只是想知道你在研究中是否看到了这一点。嗯，你知道，文化是如此广泛。有太多不同类型的文化。如果你去尼泊尔，如果你去印度，我和奇普都去过
been, if you look at some of those cultures where they, the james, they don't even want you to step on an ant on the floor because that would be a sign of aggression. Then you look at some of the southern United States subcultures where there is this culture of, of getting, of, of gregion, even, of being macho, of taking the bull by the horns, no matter what the outcome. The culture is so broad that I don't think I could make a firm statement about it. Chip, any thoughts? Are you right? You know, it's a great, yeah, I mean, I can share personal stories from my travels of how anger sort of looks differently in different cultures, but I think what's important to remember
去过那里，如果你看看其中一些文化，他们，比如耆那教徒，甚至不希望你踩到地板上的一只蚂蚁，因为那将是攻击的标志。然后你看看美国南部的一些亚文化，那里存在着一种获取、争强好胜的文化，甚至是崇尚男子气概、不惜一切代价迎难而上的文化。文化是如此广泛，以至于我认为我无法对此做出明确的陈述。奇普，有什么想法吗？你说得对，你知道，这是一个很好的……是的，我的意思是，我可以分享我旅行中的个人故事，关于愤怒在不同文化中看起来如何不同，但我认为重要的是要记住
is that anger as a basic emotion does exist across. all cultures. So whether you live in the most remote rainforest in the world or the most cosmopolitan city, you're wired to experience anger. What changes drastically across cultures are the expressive patterns that are sort of permitted within that culture. And so you see more expressive cultures and cultures that are less expressive. I found in my travels that when you go to countries where expressing anger is not considered appropriate. People are still angry and you sit down and have lunch with them and, you know, they're kind of gossiping negatively and sort of, you know, kind of undermining some of their enemies and colleagues. They're not looking angry, but they're doing it in different ways.
愤怒作为一种基本情绪确实存在于所有文化中。所以无论你生活在世界上最偏远的雨林还是最国际化的城市，你的基因里都有体验愤怒的机制。在不同文化中发生巨大变化的是在该文化中某种程度上被允许的表达模式。因此，你会看到更多表达性强的文化和表达性较弱的文化。我在旅行中发现，当你去到那些表达愤怒被认为是不合适的国家时。人们仍然在生气，你坐下来和他们吃午饭，你知道，他们会进行负面八卦，并且有点，你知道，在暗中破坏他们的一些敌人和同事。他们看起来并没有生气，但他们是以不同的方式在做这件事。
And so I think anger is always there. It's just what are the rules of the culture that permit anger or sort of dampen certain expressive patterns down. Yeah, I would say, Chip, not only the rules of the culture, but maybe the rules of the individual. And by that, I mean, I've been to Russia quite a few times, as has Chip. And I think back in the late 1990s, I did a large-scale study of anger and what we call our anger model, meaning look at the various components of anger. And basically, I found no differences. The Russians responded to our anger model, which was basically the triggers of anger, what you thought about the trigger, et cetera, et cetera.
所以我觉得愤怒一直都在。只是文化的规则是什么，它允许愤怒，或者说压制某些表达模式。是的，我想说，奇普，不仅是文化的规则，也许还有个人的规则。我的意思是，我去过俄罗斯好几次，奇普也是。我想在20世纪90年代末，我做过一项关于愤怒的大规模研究，以及我们所谓的愤怒模型，意思是观察愤怒的各种组成部分。基本上，我没有发现任何差异。俄罗斯人对我们的愤怒模型反应完全一致，该模型基本上就是愤怒的诱因、你对诱因的想法，等等等等。
Russians and Americans responded exactly the same way. Yet, as we make this broadcast today, Putin is invading Ukraine. So, and he's acting, I believe, as a dictator, meaning as a single, single-minded person. So when we talk about anger and aggression, I think there may be broad cultural differences, but there are also an awful lot of individual differences. So one of the things that we like to do when we're talking about these kinds of issues for our listeners is to try to give them some effective strategies if they're struggling with the question at hand. And I'm wondering, I know you've both written a book about this.
俄罗斯人和美国人的反应完全一样。然而，正如我们今天进行这场广播一样，普京正在入侵乌克兰。所以，他正在行动，我认为他是一个独裁者，意味着他是一个固执己见、独断专行的人。因此，当我们谈论愤怒和攻击性时，我认为可能存在广泛的文化差异，但也存在大量的个体差异。因此，当我们为听众讨论这类问题时，我们喜欢做的事情之一就是尝试在他们正与手头的问题作斗争时，给他们一些有效的策略。我想知道，我知道你们俩都写过关于这方面的书。
What are the highlights of what you found around the most effective strategies that people can use to manage their own anger? People who don't necessarily need to go for a clinical intervention but are trying to work through things themselves. Yeah, we may have different answers on this. I think for me, one of it, one of them is to ask yourself, is this issue all that important? If my child was not selected for the school play, if the other worker at work did get a better desk, if any of those things occurred, is this really such a big deal? Is it such an awful and terrible and horrible thing? We have lots of examples we could give where the child who's not selected for the school play, who's treated unfairly, goes on to be a great actor, right?
关于人们可以用来管理自己愤怒的最有效策略，你发现了哪些亮点？那些不一定需要进行临床干预，而是试图自己解决问题的人。是的，我们对此可能会有不同的答案。我想对我来说，其中之一就是问问自己，这个问题真的那么重要吗？如果我的孩子没有被选上学校的戏剧，如果单位里的另一个同事确实得到了更好的办公桌，如果这些事情发生了，这真的是一件大事吗？这是一件那么糟糕、可怕和恐怖的事情吗？我们可以举出很多例子，那些没有被选上学校的戏剧、受到不公对待的孩子，后来成了一名伟大的演员，对吧？
Because it's motivating. So we don't really know the answer to what various life events will have on our future. And if there's a simple thing I would say is think about whether it's worthwhile, making a mountain out of a molehill in the issue that's affecting you right now. Kim, I think there's reason for optimism that there's been a handful of sort of meta-analytic reviews in the treatment area, and they all point to the same conclusion that people that get treatment do better than people that don't. There is a little less clarity around what is, what are the best interventions for anger? We don't have as much research to sort of point to,
因为这具有激励作用。所以我们其实并不知道各种生活事件会对我们的未来产生什么影响。如果要说一个简单的方法，那就是考虑一下，把当前影响你的问题小题大做是否值得。金，我认为有理由保持乐观，因为在治疗领域有过一些元分析综述，它们都指向同一个结论：接受治疗的人比不接受治疗的人表现得更好。对于什么是最好的愤怒干预措施，目前还不是那么明朗。我们没有足够的研究来指出，
is there a treatment of choice? And so that question gets asked a lot. What should I be doing to manage my anger? The bad news is we don't have a treatment of choice. The good news is we don't have a treatment of choice. And there's a number of things that practitioners and individuals can do to combat their own sort of anger patterns and still be evidence-based. And so we kind of liken, in our approach at least, we would liken it to a menu dream. approach. It's kind of like going to a restaurant and selecting those interventions that seem to fit best with the context of your life and the kinds of anger problems that you're having. And I can read to you some of those from the list, but this could be a very long conversation. But I think there's things like managing your lifestyle, getting enough sleep, eating, you know, watching your eating habits. We teach people that they don't have to confront everything. Agree to let go of some things. You don't have to confront, you know, you don't have to be the
是否存在首选疗法？所以这个问题经常被问到。我应该怎么做来管理我的愤怒？坏消息是我们没有首选疗法。好消息是我们也没有首选疗法。从业者和个人可以采取多种方法来对抗他们自己的愤怒模式，同时仍然基于证据。因此，至少在我们的方法中，我们会把它比作点菜式的approach（方法）。这有点像去餐厅，选择那些最符合你生活环境和你所遇到的愤怒问题的干预措施。我可以为你宣读清单中的一些内容，但这可能会是一个很长的对话。但我认为有些事情，比如管理你的生活方式、保证充足的睡眠、饮食，你知道的，注意你的饮食习惯。我们教导人们，他们不必与每件事都针锋相对。学会放手一些事情。你不必针锋相对，你知道，你不必成为
policeman of the universe and, you know, scream and yell out your window when someone cuts you off. So learning to sidestep provocations. Instead of reacting on autopilot, try to come up with some innovative ways to respond to some of the challenges in your life. There's a whole bunch of interventions around relaxation, mindfulness, meditation that get people to calm their body, to slow down their impulsive decision-making. One of my favorites is exposure, the kind of way you think about exposure interventions for anxiety, where we actually practice with people dealing with some of the challenging scenarios in their lives and have them come up with better behaviors. Then there's a whole bunch of interventions in the thinking area, helping people kind of
宇宙的警察，你知道的，当有人插队时，在窗户大喊大叫。所以要学会避开挑衅。与其凭自动驾驶仪做出反应，不如想出一些创新的方法来应对生活中的一些挑战。还有一大堆关于放松、正念、冥想的干预措施，能让人平静身体，减缓冲动决策。我最喜欢的一种是暴露疗法，类似于你对焦虑暴露疗法的看法，我们实际上与人们一起练习应对他们生活中一些具有挑战性的场景，让他们想出更好的行为。然后是思考领域的一大堆干预措施，帮助人们
look at their thoughts in the moment when they're angry and try to be more realistic and less distorted. Then we had this idea of just kind of going through life with a more flexible philosophy. there's also some good information bubbling up around teaching people to approach life with a little bit more forgiveness and compassion. And then we have a whole area of just teaching people's skills for how they sort of negotiate outcomes with people, how we mentioned assertiveness training. But sometimes we'll teach people just basic interpersonal skills like what are you doing with your hands when you're talking to people and disagreeing with them? How loud is your tone of voice? How close do you get to them? And so sometimes our clients can benefit some really basic.
在生气时审视自己当下的想法，尽量更加现实，减少扭曲。然后我们有了这种想法，即带着更具弹性的哲学去生活；围绕着教导人们以更多的宽容和同情心来对待生活的良好信息也正在涌现。接着，我们还有一个完整的领域，即教导人们如何与他人协商结果的技能，正如我们提到的果断训练。但有时我们会教人们一些基本的人际关系技能，比如你在和别人说话并意见不合时，你的手在做什么？你的语调有多大？你离他们有多近？所以有时我们的客户可以受益于一些非常基础的技能指导。
coaching in their skills. And so there's not one intervention. There's a whole host of things here. And Howie, I don't know how you'd answer that question about what the best treatment is for people that have anger problems. You know, I think Kim's question was, could I come up with like one thing to say? And that's why I went to the don't make a mountain out of a mole hill. But I think everything that you say is absolutely correct chip and on the money. And I'm totally with you. So I would now come back and say, one of the things that I think people can do is read self-help books. Because what Chip has just gone through is our series of interventions, which basically include worksheets, explanations, opportunities for practice.
因此，并没有单一的干预措施。这里有一大堆方法。哈维，我不知道你对“有愤怒问题的人最好的治疗方法是什么”这个问题会怎么回答。你知道，我想金的问题是，我能不能想出一句话来概括？这就是为什么我会提到“不要小题大说”。但我认为你所说的一切绝对是正确的，切普，说到点子上了。我完全赞同你。所以我现在要回过头来说，我认为人们可以做的事情之一就是阅读自助书籍。因为切普刚才讲过的是我们的一系列干预措施，基本上包括工作表、解释和练习机会。
So yes, all of the data show that going to a mental health professional like a scientific, psychologist trained in the area of anger does work, will be helpful. Those are the meta-analysis. But reading some good self-help books can also be helpful. Now, I want to be, I want to say something I think is important to you. There are a lot of not good self-help books out there, books that are telling you that you have a volcano inside of you that's erupting, for example. I think Chip and I do not believe you have a volcano inside of you. I think the only thing you have inside of you is your heart and your liver and your pancreas and all that kind of stuff. So what you really want is books, and there are a few of them out there, ours, but some others,
所以是的，所有的数据都表明，去找心理健康专家，比如在愤怒领域接受过培训的科学心理学家，确实管用，会有所帮助。这些就是元分析。但阅读一些好的自助书籍也会有所帮助。现在，我想说一件我认为对你很重要的事。市面上有很多不好的自助书籍，比如那些告诉你体内有一座火山正在爆发的书。我想切普和我都不认为你体内有一座火山。我认为你体内唯一的东西就是你的心脏、肝脏、胰腺和诸如此类的东西。所以你真正想要的是书籍——市面上确实有几本，包括我们的和其他一些——
by people who've been studying anger for all of their lives. I mean, Chip and I have been doing this, I have to say, since the early 1990s. And we do have maybe, I'm going to say, 10 other professionals around the United States who've also been in the anger area and have been studying it as their life mission since the 1990s. And they've put out a series of self-help books, as we have, that can be very effective. But be careful about the ones that are talking about in the volcanoes or making false promises, those are the ones you're going to be careful of. Yeah, I think our advice is to seek out credentialed, licensed practitioners that have some experience in the area, whether you're
由那些一生都在研究愤怒的人所写的。我是说，切普和我一直在做这件事，我不得不说，从20世纪90年代初开始。在美国，我们大概还有其他10位左右的专业人士，他们也将愤怒领域作为他们的生活使命，从20世纪90年代就开始进行研究。他们和我们一样，出版了一系列自助书籍，这些书非常有效。但要小心那些谈论火山或做出虚假承诺的书，那些是你需要小心的。是的，我认为我们的建议是寻找有资质、有执照的从业者，他们在该领域有一些经验，无论你是在谈论
talking about consuming self-help materials or going to see a professional in the context of a therapeutic treatment. What I've noticed over the last five or 10 years with the increase in social media is mental health professionals giving a list of what they consider themselves to be expert in. And they list maybe 20 different areas, anxiety and depression and anorexia and nervosa and marital problems and geriatric and what have you. Chip and I don't say that. Chip and I say anger has been our life passion. And there, as they said, there is. 10 or 15 other people that really have made that anger, their life passion. Those are the ones that I would be trying to consult with and to read their books. Well, thank you. I think that's been
消费自助材料，还是在治疗环境中去看专业人士。在过去五到十年里，随着社交媒体的兴起，我注意到心理健康专家列出了他们自认为精通的领域清单。他们列出了大约20个不同的领域，比如焦虑、抑郁、神经性厌食症、婚姻问题、老年病等等。切普和我不这么说。切普和我说，愤怒是我们一生的激情所在。正如他们所说，确实还有其他10到15人真正把愤怒作为他们一生的激情。那些才是我会尝试咨询并阅读他们书籍的人。嗯，谢谢。我认为这是
very helpful advice, and I hope our listeners appreciate that. We'll try to have some resources on our webpage for people to refer to. So I appreciate you're joining me today. Dr. Tafredi, Dr. Kastinov. Thank you very much. Thank you. My pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org.
非常宝贵的建议，我希望我们的听众能体会到这一点。我们会在网页上提供一些资源供大家参考。因此，非常感谢你今天加入我的节目，塔弗迪博士，卡斯特诺夫博士。非常感谢。不客气，我的荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》的往期节目。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那就是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起拼写，在 APA.org。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiion. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学对话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪翁（Chris Condiion）。感谢收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。